JOINING US FROM ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
LET’S BRING IN JASON CHAFFETZ,
FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT AND GOVERNMENT REFORM
COMMITTEE.
A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT, JASON, SO, IT SOUNDS
AS IF WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY TRIED TO GET LOANS
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM, SOMETHING
LIKE $70 BILLION HAS ALREADY
BEEN PROCESSED.
250,000 SMALL BUSINESSES SO FAR.
CLEARLY THERE IS A NEED.
AND CLEARLY, PERHAPS, THEY UNDER
ESTIMATED HOW MUCH MONEY THEY
WOULD NEED UP FRONT OR IS THIS
JUST HOW WASHINGTON WORKS?
GET A LITTLE NOW, GET A LITTLE
LATER?
>> IT’S JUST HOW WASHINGTON
WORKS.
THEY GOT THE MONEY OUT IN A
REMARKABLE FAST TIME.
I TALKED TO A COMPANY YESTERDAY
WHO ACTUALLY GOT FUNDED.
I REALIZE THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHERS THAT ARE WAITING.
I THINK CONGRESS KNEW THAT
$2 TRILLION IS ALREADY A BIG
NUMBER.
THEY NEEDED TO START THIS BUT
THEY KNEW THERE WAS GOING TO GOI
HAVE TO BE FOURTH PACKAGE TO
COME IN BEHIND IT.
HOPEFULLY THEY DON’T LADDER IT L
CONGRESS IS NOTORIOUS FOR DOING
IT.
THEY PROBABLY WILL.
BRIAN: GET THE MONEY EARMARKED
TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO SMALL
BUSINESS.
AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT MONEY
THAT’S GIVEN TO ALL THE STATES.
THE STATES AREN’T EQUIPPED TO
GIVE ANYONE UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHAT ARE PEOPLE GOING TO DO AS
THEY WAIT FOR THEIR 1200.
AS THEY WAIT FOR THEIR LOANS,
GRANTS, AND THINK WAIT FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS?
MEANWHILE BILL BARR WAS ON WITH
LAURA AND TALKED ABOUT WHERE
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED IN
CHINA AND THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IN CHINA.
AND W.H.O., ALWAYS SIDING WITH
CHINA.
AND NOT TELLING US THE TRUTH
ABOUT HOW BAD THINGS WERE.
BILL BARR WEIGHS IN.
>> BIGGER THREAT TO AMERICA’S
ELECTION SECURITY, RUSSIA OR
CHINA?
>> IN MY OPINION, IT’S CHINA.
AND NOT JUST TO THE ELECTION
PROCESS, BUT I THINK ACROSS THE
BOARD.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO COMPARISON.
CHINA IS A VERY SERIOUS THREAT
TO THE UNITED STATES.
GEOPOLITICALLY, ECONOMICALLY,
MILITARILY, AND A THREAT TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
GIVEN THEIR ABILITY TO INFLUENCE
THINGS.
BRIAN: IS THIS THE TIME TO TAKE
THEM ON OR SHOULD WE WAIT FOR
THE PANDEMIC TO SUBSIDE IF, IN
FACT, JASON CHAFFETZ YOU DO
AGREE WITH BILL BARR’S
ASSESSMENT?
>> I THINK BILL BARR IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU WORRY ABOUT
RUSSIA, YOU WORRY ABOUT IRAN,
YOU WORRY ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
BUT, LONG TERM, AND SHORT-TERM,
CHINA HAS THE RESOURCES AND THEY
ARE GENERALLY MUCH SMARTER AND
MUCH QUIETER ABOUT HOW THEY GO
ABOUT CORPORATE ESPIONAGE.
ESPIONAGE ON OUR GOVERNMENT, ON
OUR MILITARY.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN OUTER
SPACE THAT A LOT OF AMERICANS
THAT DON’T HAVE ANY EXPOSURE TO.
THERE IS A REASON WHY AMERICAN
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP, PUT UP
HIS SPACE FORCE AND CHINA IS A
BIG PART OF THE REASON WHY TO DO
THAT.
BUT, ALSO, THE ECONOMIC TIES.
AND WHEN WE THROW OUT
$22 TRILLION IN DEBT, AND THEN
GO TO THE CHINESE AND THE
JAPANESE AND THE OTHERS AND SAY
BUY OUR DEBT, WE CREATE AN
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
ANYBODY WHO HAS LOOKED AT ANY
EXEDGES IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
CERTAINLY DURING THE YEARS THAT
I WAS THERE, RECOGNIZES THAT
CHINA IS THE BIGGEST THREAT.
AINSLEY: SO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
IS SAYING THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT, DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ESTABLISHMENT ONE WHEN BERNIE
DROPPED OUT YESTERDAY AND
LEAVING BIDEN TO GET THAT
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINATION.
LAST NIGHT BERNIE WAS ON THE
LATE SHOW AFTER DROPPING OUT.
AND THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH JOE TO MOVE HIM IN A MORE
PROGRESSIVE DIRECTION.
AND I THINK JOE IS A GOOD
POLITICIAN.
AND HE UNDERSTANDS THAT IN ORDER
TO DEFEAT THE PRESIDENT, IN
ORDER TO DEFEAT TRUMP, HE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BRING NEW
PEOPLE INTO HIS POLITICAL WORLD.
AND THAT HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
LISTEN TO THEIR NEEDS, YOUNG
PEOPLE, WORKING PEOPLE.
AND MAYBE START MOVING IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION TO SOME
DEGREE THAN HE HAS IN THE PAST.
AINSLEY: JASON, DO YOU THINK
THAT WILL HAPPEN?
>> OH, BERNIE, BERNIE, BERNIE.
HE DIDN’T REALLY GET OUT OF
RACE.
HE JUST SENT A TROJAN HORSE IN
THERE TO TRY TO DISRUPT THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BERNIE NEVER JOINED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE WEIGHS THE MAJOR DISRUPTER
AND NOW HE IS GOING TO CAUSE ALL
KINDS OF HEADACHES FOR JOE
BIDEN.
IF I’M THE BIDEN CAMP, I’M
ABSOLUTELY TICKED AT THIS GUY.
INSTEAD OF WRAPPING MY ARM
AROUND JOE BIDEN AND DEFEAT HIM
AND BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
HE DIDN’T DO THAT.
HE TOLD HIS PEOPLE TO KEEP ON
GOING, KEEP FIGHTING.
GO TO THAT CONVENTION AND EFFECT
A PLATFORM THAT WORKS ALL TO THE
ADVANTAGE OF DONALD TRUMP.
IT’S GOING TO MAKE JOE BIDEN DO
THINGS THAT ARE WORSE THAN HE
WANTS TO DO.
AND, REMEMBER, JOE BIDEN HAS HIS
OWN PROBLEM.
IT’S JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED FOUR YEARS
BEFORE JIMMY CARTER BECAME THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE GUY HAS BEEN LOCKED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND NOW HE HAS GOT THIS BERNIE
SANDERS PROBLEM.
AND HE HAS GOT A DONALD TRUMP
WHO IS DOING AN A-PLUS JOB ON
THIS CORONAVIRUS.
AND AN ECONOMY THAT I DO BELIEVE
WILL COME ROARING BACK.
STEVE: WELL, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
TALKING TO CHUCK ROCHA.
YOU KNOW CHUCK, JUST ABOUT 50
MINUTES AGO, JASON.
AND HE SAID LOOK, THIS HAS BEEN
SUCH A CRAZY PRIMARY SEASON.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT.
SO YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT THROWS A MONKEY WRENCH INTO
THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
BUT, ULTIMATELY, BERNIE IS
LOOKING FOR INFLUENCE AND HE
WANTS HIS SUPPORTERS TO FEEL
LIKE SOMEBODY IS LISTENING TO
HIM.
OTHERWISE, THEY’RE NOT GOING TO
SHOW UP FOR JOE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I THINK HE IS ENCOURAGING ALL
OF HIS SUPPORTERS TO ACTUALLY
SHOW UP.
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR VOICE
IS HEARD AT THE CONVENTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DIVERSE PARTY.
WE WANT EVERY FACTION OF THE
PARTY TO BE HEARD AT THE
CONVENTION.
OUR COALITION COULDN’T WIN THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN BY HIMSELF AND HIS
COALITION CAN’T WIN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
TOGETHER IS THE ONLY WAY THAT
THEY HAVE ANY SHOT AT ALL OF
WINNING IT.
LOOK, WE MAY NOT GET EVERYTHING
THAT WE WANT.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME KIND OF
COMING TOGETHER OF EVERYBODY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, JASON, BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC REALLY CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES, IT WAS ALL ABOUT
POLITICS.
IT SEEMED LIKE THAT WAS OUR LEAD
STORY FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS ABOUT THE CAMPAIGN AND
THE PRIMARY SEASON.
NOW, UNTIL THIS THING GETS
BETTER, AND WE CROSS THE PEAK
AND WE GO WAY DOWN THE CURVE,
ARE PEOPLE REALLY TUNED IN TO
THIS?
>>
>> KNOW, WHAT BERNIE SANDERS DID
YESTERDAY IS JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
REALITY.
HE CAN’T HAVE HIS RALLIES.
HE CAN’T GO OUT AND CAMPAIGN THE
WAY HE TRADITIONALLY DID.
AND SO WHEN HE SAYS HE IS
LEAVING THE RACE.
HE IS NOT REALLY GETTING OUT OF
IT BECAUSE HE IS TELLING PEOPLE
TO FIGHT ON, HE IS GETTING THE
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTERS OUT THERE
TO LAY DOWN THEIR ARMS AND SAY,
YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE ARE NOT GOING TO FIGHT
ANYMORE AND MEANWHILE BERNIE
SANDERS IS GOING TO’ PEOPLE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SHOW UP.
LET’S BE HONEST JOE BIDEN
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
HEY DID I TELL YOU I RAN WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND IS HE GOING
TO BE GOING THE WHOLE SUMMER.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING TO BE
INTRIGUING.
I AM SURE WE WILL HEAR MORE
ABOUT THAT SHORTLY.
EVIDENTLY OWE TALKED TO BERNIE
SANDERS A COUPLE DAYS AGO WHICH
LED TO THIS.